one of the interesting things is when i
talk to people normally it's okay let's
talk about season two you know picard
season two is about you know it's about
to come out blah blah blah but you're
actually filming picard season three
right now as well
so uh for fans is season two and season
three sort of like
all interconnected or is each one sort
of a self-contained entity if you will
each season is a self-contained entity
but they do speak to each other so
you know and i would like to believe
that after you watch all three of them
there has been a gross arc
that we have tried to do but no each one
is
you know you know and you know season
one
very much
michael and me season two very much me
and terry season three very much terry
you know like there's a little bit of a
glide in terms of
you know people being dead in the center
of it or moving around or and each
person has a slightly different star
trek in their mind
sure what what do you want to tease fans
about season two and what they should be
excited for um obviously i've seen the
first three episodes and you have a
board you have q
um it's it's cool what can you tease
people well i think the three episodes
are
delightful and exciting and a little bit
deceiving only in that now the show
slows down
now it sort of lands in that
in our present and stays there till the
end of the show and what it explores are
relationships and to me that i i find
that exciting that yeah
because i'm old uh you know the idea
that we are talking about connection and
intimacy and why we feel we can or can't
get close to people uh and those
struggles in picard's life really most
primarily are the journey of the season
although they will be reflected in
struggles
that are embodied by the rest of the
crew because that's why we have a group
no completely um what was your listen
obviously it's cool to know that you
have an ending like paramount's
basically knowing that season three is
the end you can sort of build towards
that um i have to ask you were you
involved in the writing of the series
finale have you read the script and what
was your reaction with it
i will not answer that question
i listen this is my job i got to try
these no totally i this is this is my
whole you know i gotta try well let me
ask you this
bringing back q i love q um and i'm just
curious how much fun is it to write for
q and is it almost a little challenging
to write for q because fans love the
characters so much
so it's not challenging to write for
cube because fans love him because god
knows they love picard right like you
know the truth is you know you do that
like that's the job as you get it but
what is challenging about q is you know
he's the genie with a million wishes you
know and boy does that [ __ ] up
storytelling because you know he can do
anything he wants to and although it's
sustainable for an hour you can't do it
for 10. so um you know so
you'll see our queue has guardrails
um and those guardrails speak to his
existential condition and i think that
uh
that's an interesting cue to put up
against an older picard
uh my i think i have time for another
question um what do you actually think
fans of picard would be surprised to
learn about like the
the behind the scenes the making of the
show the writing of the show things that
maybe don't get you know it's not in the
limelight
uh patrick is funny
okay
you know i mean patrick likes a joke he
is convivial i mean he's sort of you
know picard can be quite serious
and not to say patrick can't be serious
but patrick's baseline demeanor is nazir
it's kind of
you know a little bit bone vault
sure did you did you oh i got a rap but
did you know you did you know that the
doctor strange trailer was coming with
him in it or when you saw it were you
like oh my god
i i i i might not have i might i might
know things i might not know things
i don't know anything i
like to know things
i i uh yeah i gotta go i knew uh i knew
that i know some stuff about that movie
and i think fans are going to be very
excited i'll say it like that um we'll
talk again real soon awesome
you